The Joe Rogan Experience now I don't
know if this if they have to take
additional precautions due to traveling
with hazardous waste and whether or not
those precautions were or not taken
that's what I'm hearing about this case
is that they that this is something that
they were trying to cut money by
transporting these things that are
hazardous wastes in a way that perhaps
maybe they shouldn't have been
transported that way or maybe the
regulation should be different I don't
know if it's even hazardous waste though
I think it's just chemicals that we use
in plastic oh it's very hazardous it's
not waste right hazardous materials
right right it's very hazardous material
it's like the byproduct yeah no it's
it's very dangerous material but that's
why there's this one kid Nick Drumm
who's been doing these amazing Tic Tacs
that I'm obsessed with because it's that
he's like a chemist yeah he and he's
great he's great he's actually taking
what the APA is releasing and he's
trying to make sense of it and he's like
why am I the person who's doing this why
am I the person who's asking these
questions because what he mentions is
when you look at the Manifest of the
chemicals that were on there why what
we're looking at is this they're doing
you know what's in the air but also he
was saying there's petroleum so we're
talking about an oil spill too but no
one's talking about that well let's play
what he has to say rewind that joke he
has a bunch
well just let's play this one play the
one you have in front of you okay and
Rewind that
stop sound
play yeah I don't know if that's his
ticket
has been very good so let's talk about
the trail derailment in East Palestine
Ohio East palestine's about an hour
north of Pittsburgh almost halfway to
Cleveland Norfolk Southern has a rail
line that goes right through town and
this derailment happened right on the
edge outside of town on the border of PA
in Ohio the cars that crashed fine for
them contain Vinyl chloride it's a
monomer used to make PVC the reporting
on this has gotten Vinyl chloride
confused with polyvinyl chloride the
polymer made out of vinyl chloride now
the reason that this distinction is
really important is vinyl chloride is
very hazardous and very flammable
polyvinyl chloride is a Plastics that's
used in like everything the other thing
about Vinyl chloride is that it boils at
eight degrees Fahrenheit so it's shipped
in its liquid form meaning that when
these trains crashed and they started
leaking they weren't just leaking liquid
that they were spewing boiling gas so
vinyl chloride is really toxic OSHA has
the permissible limit of how much you
can be exposed to it during an eight
hour shift as a one PPM part per million
average over eight hours so prior to
this the biggest spill of this chemical
was in New Jersey where one train car
and about 23 000 gallons of vinyl
chloride were spilled but it couldn't
catch on fire now this crash in Ohio has
five Training cars these kinds of tanker
cars can carry between 25 and 33 000
gallons let's call it 250 to 250 000
pounds of vinyl chloride that's per
train car five train cars there's maybe
a million pounds of this toxic chemical
spilling into the ground and also
boiling off into the air but then it
caught on fire I think this is where the
reporting is really bad because no one
is mentioning what the byproduct of
vinyl chloride burning is of the many
byproducts of burning vinyl chloride one
of them is hydrogen chloride hydrogen
chloride is really unstable and latches
onto water like just water vapor in the
atmosphere and that turns into
hydrochloric acid so right now
government officials officials from the
railroad both the governor of
Pennsylvania and Ohio are calling
burning off the million pounds of this
stuff a success but not mentioning that
it means that we have hundreds of
thousands of pounds of acid in the air
potentially now ever since engineering
school I've studied a lot of industrial
accidents I just find it really
fascinating and organizations like the
chemical safety board and TSB at OSHA
all have like really good reports
available to the public I think as a
designer it's really good to learn about
mistakes when looking at these kinds of
industrial disasters across time there
are a couple things that are pretty
Universal across all of them one the
responsible party in this Coast Norfolk
Southern Railway always plays down the
reality of the situation politicians
also just repeat the same lines and then
news outlets just repeat the same so all
we're hearing is the responsible party's
word this hasn't been getting so Jamie I
also sent you a video that shows what it
looks like in the area where these
clouds are passing over and it is
horrific it's apocalyptic it's so
terrible there's a man who's on the
ground who's screaming that these aren't
storm clouds these are the clouds that
of this [__] that they're burning from
East Palestine and he's freaking out and
you know like animals are dying pets are
dying fish are dying in the rivers it's
in the idea that they only evacuated a
small area yeah you're talking about
like miles and miles away from this yeah
animals are dying this is it look at
this play this Go full screen with this
because these aren't there aren't storm
clouds
this is the [__] [__]
that they burn off the [__] [__] they
burn off and he's Palestine this
storm clouds look at this I know look at
it
this is over Darlington
this is [__] insane if you if you're
just listening what we're looking at is
just intense black clouds covering this
area and it's daytime yeah and you can't
see [__] you the sky is completely
covered in Black play give me the
volumes this for me balancing
they're [__] controlled burn
yeah the idea is a controlled burn is so
crazy well I guess because they were
worried that it was going to explode
that's why they felt they had to burn it
but it did explode right no they were
felt it was going to be a massive
explosion and this would have happened
anyway
but there's no other options like in one
of that kids tick tocks later on he
talks about how they just buried it and
so people are saying they did this just
to get the trains running again
basically which again the cynic in me
wouldn't doubt but I don't know I just
sent you a text from
um my editor Joe donatelli who I loved
from Playboy he now lives in Ohio and
he's on does local news and I will say
local news has been great on this
they're actually reporting and he like
he said to me you have to be able to
like muster the resources fact check
things it it isn't as fast as the
internet where there's a void of
information that gets filled and he did
a long Thread about what they've learned
in his at the local news station where
he is that's really good and I recommend
people go check it out because I think
local news is actually pretty good on
this but some people in Ohio are saying
they didn't even know about it
there's like people who are you'll see
online they're like I'm in Ohio and I
didn't hear about this but maybe they
don't watch local news